rassurez-vous ce sandwich se termine
bien un moment donné mais pour l'instant
une quarantaine de boulanger éleveurs de
porcs et producteur de riz yates à faire
pour battre un record de france celui du
sandwich de rillettes le plus long et
pour l'occasion une véritable brigade
s'est mise en marche
il ya l'équipe qui va chercher le pain
et des couples parents ensuite l'équipe
qui met et qui étale gracieusement toute
la rillette gp2 tôt surtout les casse
croûte est où les sandwichs sont ensuite
alignés sur 74 m 74 m soit 2 m de plus
que le record détenu par les sarthois
et c'est sous le contrôle d'un huissier
qu'en moins de deux heures 150 baguette
et 50 kg de rillettes ont été utilisés
mais m
un record battu une fierté régionale
retrouver et surtout une bonne action
réalisée aujourd'hui les artisans on est
sensible au gaspillage alimentaire et on
n'a pas le droit de jouer avec la
nourriture
donc on a décidé de reverser
intégralement la recette à une
association qui s'appelle magie à
l'hôpital
l'hôpital clocheville des enfants
malades voilà et c'est notre façon à
nous de dire eh bien on aide les enfants
sont déjà bien malheureux comme ça en
étant malade
découpé en plusieurs centaines de
morceaux et vendu un public très
nombreux le sandwich de rillettes le
plus long de france a permis d'offrir un
chèque de 1500 euros à l'association
magie à l'hôpital